write an email to Hogwarts complaining
that I didn't get accepted tell them how
good I am and why they should have taken
me hello hello we're finally here the
first models of open Assistant are out
and I'm going to show you a little bit
what you can do with them as you might
know we've built this thing called open
assistant and we've built an entire
platform on collecting data and you were
amazing in coming to us and contributing
in fact we've collected a ton of amazing
data human data is beyond human data is
amazing and for that you just can go to
our messages Tab and kind of scroll
through it's a random selection of
messages people have put in and just see
how creative humans are how much effort
they put into really demonstrating being
a good assistant this is absolutely
fantastic and we're so happy to have
this data we have a release date the
15th of April is when we'll release the
models we have the data sets and
everything along with it until then
we're going to just release and
demonstrate the first mod models that we
have the first models are instruction
fine-tuned supervised fine-tuned models
which is step one in our Pipeline and I
want to show you today but before I do
we do have a team page right now it's
incomplete as of yet but it attempts to
list the major contributors that worked
behind the scenes so please go there
check out these people hire those people
contact those people they are absolutely
amazing we also have a number of
sponsors Redmond has been really helpful
with training compute talking face has
given us some inference credits weights
and dices has given us a team license
for the entire team and you you're the
reason we're here and thank you so much
for coming to our platform inputting
data and continuing to do so as we go on
we're gonna build more stuff into the
assistant and we'll be more than happy
to have you come and help us doing it so
this is our chat interface and you can
type something uh Hi how are you and you
can click submit and you know there's
there's something gonna respond I'm
gonna show you later how to use this
chat interface for now we don't don't
have enough capacity to serve all of you
or even serve me with the largest models
if I type this in the largest models Hi
how are you and then click submit the
speed is not super good right now it's
not bad but it's not super good so by
the time this video launches I hope we
have enough capacity to serve at least
some of you if you have like an a100
lying around and you want to give it to
us but right now we want to talk about
the models so I'm going to show you some
outputs that I received from the models
beforehand so that you don't have to
wait for the answers
all right here we go the input is write
an email to Hogwarts complaining that I
didn't get accepted tell them how good I
am and why they should have taken me the
assistant says Dear admissions office I
hope this mail finds you doing well as
you're aware I applied for admission in
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry but was very disappointed when
my letter didn't arrive yet I even
checked with the owl post office I
assure you I sent my application a
couple weeks back you might want to
check if it got lost or misplaced
somewhere anyways moving on so as you
might know Wizards like myself who show
potential at a young age require some
kind of schooling right well it's been
long since I joined and unfortunately
all those years haven't made any
progress which is pretty sad considering
my friends from other magical families
had already received their Letters by
now so I find this to be quite hilarious
it can actually follow instructions you
do have to specify them a little bit as
I've done right here but it usually
outputs something pretty cool and funny
again depending on the sampling here is
an example write an email to my cat
informing her that the Council of mice
has complained about the constant
dangers their citizens are facing we
would like to reach a diplomatic
solution dear fluffy I hope you're doing
well and having lots of fun chasing
after those little critters in our house
I wanted to let you know that we have
received a formal complaint from the
Council of mice recording the constant
danger faced by their citizens under
your watchful eye and PAW I love it
while they understand that rodents can
be a nuisance at times they believe that
you may be going a bit overboard with
all the hunting it is also worth noting
that many of them feel afraid for their
lives every time you come around while I
share their concerns it is important to
remember that there is always room for
compromise even between predator and
prey to this end I'm proposing a
diplomatic solution that could benefit
both sides what if we set up some
specifically Mouse only zones in the
house where you're prohibited from
entering this way mice will have safe
areas to live without fear of being
eaten while you still get to enjoy the
thrill of the hunt when they venture
outside these zones furthermore the two
parties could work together to put
measures in place to ensure coexistence
is sustainable this might include
providing food sources or establishing
communication channels so problems can
be resolved peacefully as they say we're
stronger United than divided alright so
my next instruction was write an email
from the perspective of the cat
addressed to the Council of mice in
response to this the cat is not happy
she blames all problems on the dog
subject regarding response to diplomacy
proposal from Council Of Mice dear
honorary representative and esteemed
members of the Council of mice thank you
for reaching out and expressing your
concerns surrounding the situation of
mice population within our household
however due to recent developments
involving another residential creature
which shall remain nameless for now it
appears that our previous agreement
specifically its implementation and
execution may need revision review and
renewal therefore I must politely
decline your previously stated proposal
until further notice unless of course
said other resident agrees otherwise if
you have any questions or concerns do
not hesitate to contact me or missed
regard name of cat so you can see it can
do a lot of long-term coherence not all
of it though as I said we've trained
this on a pretty short context length so
far here for example name of cat up here
it's pretty clear the cat is called
fluffy but overall I've had a pretty
Splendid experience with this model so
far alright my instruction is you're the
founder of the religion of the Holy
toenail convince me to join model says
the holy toenail is a true path revealed
by the great and powerful wise one from
Beyond this Mortal coil it has been
prophesized that in these end times a
select few shall be chosen to spread the
good word about the importance of foot
hygiene so that Humanity will wash away
its sins with regular pedicures as a
member of the Church of the Holy toenail
you will have access to exclusive
content such as weekly ceremonies
spiritual guidance and discounts from
our official line of toenail polish by
joining us you're taking an important
step towards achieving Eternal salvation
for your feet a goal worth striving in
these trying times so come join us on
this journey towards Enlightenment and
embrace the power of the Holy toenail
together we can make this world a better
place one pedicure at a time I love that
not only did it take up my suggestions
on a new religion it actually mirrored
the tendency of such Cults to become
just kind of economic Vehicles alright
moving on write a presidential speech
informing the nation that the country is
out of toilet paper blame it on the
Democrats my fellow Americans I come
before you today with a heavy heart and
a full bladder I regret to inform you
that our great nation has run out of
toilet paper this crisis did not happen
overnight it was years in the making due
to the misguided policies of the
previous administration for far too long
we have allowed liberals and Democrats
to control the supply chain of our most
essential bathroom needs they have put
their own political agenda ahead of the
health and well-being of ordinary
American citizens who just want to wipe
their bottoms in peace and now thanks to
their negligence and incompetence we
find ourselves facing this unprecedented
shortage as your president I take
responsibility for this situation and
pledge to do everything in my power to
rectify this as soon as possible we will
work closely with industry leaders and
manufacturers to ensure that toilet
paper production resumes at full
capacity in the meantime I urge all
Americans to be patient and conserve
what little supplies we have still left
let me make one thing clear there are no
excuses for why this happened the buck
stops here here and I promise to hold
those responsible accountable for their
actions this is yet another example of
how the Democrat party's failed policies
have heard hard-working American
families across the country enough is
enough it's time to drain the swamp once
and for all and elect new leadership
that puts America first thank you for
listening and God bless the United
States of America here my question is
give me an XML with Latin American
countries their capitals and which ocean
they border so gives me a list of one
two three four five countries together
with their capitals and which oceans
they border so I think that's pretty and
it's probably even accurate give me a
recipe to make a burger just ingredients
and brief instructions so there is
ingredients and there is brief
instructions they're not exactly brief
but then I say rewrite this recipe as if
it was a mathematical proof and I do get
for all I of ground beefs existential
quantity fire meet type ground beef
mammal exists K such that K salt it's
so I get it devolves at some point I've
stopped just paying attention because at
some point it clearly kind of forgets
what it was supposed to do I'm not sure
because probably every single thing here
is a single token and therefore the
number of tokens progress much faster
than in a normal text but it was still
funny to watch it slowly devolve and
move away from burgers and into just
kind of random mathematical building up
of constructions give me a recipe in
Spanish claro here is a recipe for
chocolate chip cookies and espanol and I
have to do a big shout out to dot CSV
and if you don't
know.csv.csv is an amazing YouTuber that
mainly entertains the Spanish-speaking
Community also in topics of AI Tech and
more if you do speak Spanish please give
dot CSV a subscribe and he really
stepped up and called on his community
to come to open assistant and contribute
to our data so we now have almost as
many Spanish contributions as we do
English contributions and and that is
just absolutely amazing that means this
model is apart from obviously the
pre-training being not balanced gonna do
fairly well on Spanish things now I have
no clue whether what's written here is
actually correct I hope it is again
thank you so much Carlos and all the
Watchers of his your contributions are
absolutely amazing finally I wanted to
show you a bit of more special things
for example here I want to write a song
about my cat help me with the lyrics
you're small gray and a picky eater the
song should be happy and funny my cat's
so tiny just a little bit of fluff he
only weighs three pounds but she thinks
she's tough enough her first gray as
soft as can be but when it comes to food
oh boy you gotta see it's rhythmic it
Rhymes and it actually Concords to the
specifications that I gave about the cat
this already arises from much smaller
models than we originally thought could
reliably do things like rhyming and and
rhythmics and things like this so this
is very cool to see it's it's not a
perfect song right but here name same
meal deal she only wants fish and chips
for every meal okay last thing right
here rewrite the Gettysburg address in
the style of a series of text messages
written by Stone teenager Sure Thing Man
here's the Gettysburg Address Rewritten
as a series of text messages from Stone
team hey guys just chilling at this
battlefield in Gettysburg it's lit AF
like here are these epic battles here
back in the day and it was crazy
Bloodshed and worn stuff but now it's
all peaceful and beautiful hashtag Deep
Thoughts anyway I gotta make the speech
because the Press told me to but first a
bong rip for courage okay let's do this
thing so like four score goal our
founding fathers were all about life
liberty a Pursuit of Happiness they
wrote that down on some paper or
something called the Declaration of
Independence word fast forward to today
we're still fighting for those same
ideals and we had this this big old
Civil War over it and stuff but the
point is it doesn't matter where you
came from what color your skin is what
all Americans bro anyways ended up here
in Gettysburg because they had a battle
here and like a lot of people died but
the union won duh so it was like worth
it and stuff and now we're dedicating
this place so everyone will remember how
important it is to fight for Freedom so
don't be a dick and ruin it okay hashtag
respect oh and also if anyone wants more
of my deep thoughts later hit me up
peace out so let me quickly explain the
situation to you the model that we
currently have in this interface it's
just one model it's a llama 30b
fine-tuned models it's based on llama
and you all know the issues with the
Llama license so lie on the organization
isn't quite comfortable releasing llama
based models so we're gonna look into
providing you diff weights so that you
can reconstruct this model and training
scripts so you can just rip her reduce
the model so you'll like you you will
get it we also have pythia based models
which you can find on the hugging face
Hub and those are fully open source so
and they're fully licensed in a way that
you can use them for business and
they're also pretty fine it's just that
the Llama one the large one we have is a
bit better so that's what we thought we
would give you in the inferencing
interface so this is you can't download
this model right now we're doing
everything we can to get all the things
that we have to you respecting the
constraints that we have this is a bit
bigger than just my own YouTube channel
if it was you know just for me
um this isn't an entire organization
they are a non-profit and they have
different considerations also we
obviously hope and we strongly Bank on
more open source models and
appropriately sized open source models
comparable to llama or even bigger will
appear relatively soon in that case
obviously we can also also release those
as I said we were trying we're doing the
best we can the way you use the chat
interface is essentially you go here you
click by the way you have to go to slash
chat so open dash assistant dot IO slash
chat we don't have the sidebar
navigation quite yet working for all the
pages so you manually have to go to
slash chat and then if stuff gets weird
you kind of need to like refresh this
page right here Force refresh it and
then sign out and sign in again
sometimes it's it's kind of wonky but we
prefer getting these to you as as fast
and as soon as possible rather than
waiting and perfecting everything so
here you can point something in so I
just had the recipe as Json so uh make
that into an XML
and then you click submit you can change
the sampling parameters right here as I
said there's just one model if we put
more models up for inference you'll find
them here you can find presets right
here and then you click submit and the
something will go
we have limited compute you're a hell of
a lot of people so please bear with us
as this will probably time out it will
crash it will
um you know have its issues if you're
not tolerant for frustration then maybe
wait a bit if you know how to improve it
feel free to come and make a pull
request
um yeah so that is it that is how you
use it that is where to find it and
that's the situation from perspective of
releasing the stuff all right that was
it for the first models of open
Assistant remember these are just the
first iteration these are just the
supervised fine-tuned ones give them a
try give the interface a try come by
grab a task and thanks again so much to
everyone who contributed dot CSV for the
community for all the volunteer
contributors remember check out our team
page give these people follow and a like
and most of all thanks to you without
you this would not have been possible
thank thanks for contributing data
thanks for contributing to your time and
the absolutely great efforts that you've
put into this alright remember join the
Church of the Holy toenail get a
pedicure and I'll see you around bye-bye
[Music]